I'm Dan glass I'm the visual effects
supervisor and also one of the associate
producers on the project voyage of time
the role of visual effects supervisor it
can be a little different on every
project working with terrence malick
it's especially different in a very
broadest sense it is about looking after
anything that needs work that happens in
a computer or a digital work the film is
a documentary following a timeline of
our understanding of history and the
scientific basis upon which life has
evolved the formation of the solar
system and the proto-earth and the Sun
itself down to the origins of life the
prebiotic and then they have very very
early formation of more complex
organisms
what we did was approach scientists to
look at that spread of data and we would
work with them to actually put
real-world cameras or lenses into the
system and our job working in
collaboration with scientists which was
to add the paint and color and light
sometimes to take that somewhere more
picturesque and IMAX gives you that
amazing ability to have detail that on a
normal 35 mil or digital cinema
presentation would be very very small I
remember understand the project being so
excited to read endless and research
papers about the first fish that worked
on land at italic that you know had
elbows that they know only a certain
amount about but they know it was an
evolutionary leap and delving into the
first theorize stars giving light to the
universe right after the Big Bang we
also did a much more kind of fun
experimental things taking a lot of
practical source material which was
always Teri's Drive and throwing it into
that process and really try to make this
ultimate combination of the organic and
the digital
getting a team together that was
literally experimenting with chemicals
and smoke machines and fluid tanks that
we could create a whole range of effects
very appealing to Terry it's much more
close to you know how he intuitively
works you can obviously see and react to
things real-time
relied a lot on Natural History
Photography was really through consult
with scientific advisors as to where in
the world would be the best place to go
could stand in both for the present-day
but also the past and in some cases the
future to represent the first flora
for example Iceland in some areas has no
trees the dinosaurs we leaned heavily on
the advice of advisors as to appropriate
places that can stand in for time
periods that are much more ancient we
also have of course some extraordinary
photography now from the likes of Hubble
and some of the interplanetary space
probes that have ventured further into
our solar system and terrestrial
telescopes as well we have footage from
the Sala dynamic Observatory the sto
satellite that is around the Sun taking
4k material constantly so there's a lot
of real photographic material that we
have in our fingertips some of our
choose familiar someone which is less
familiar a project that's taken any 10
years of my time and participation is
toward helping you understand the
evolution of nature you know whether
it's the flora or fauna that is around
us the shaping of the earth that has
taken place over time we deserve to
pause sometimes I just reflect